les mal logés
c'est une mesure d'hébergement d'urgence
vous avez beaucoup de chance d'avoir pu
acheter en 200 m² dans un quartier des
congrès de paris
c'est pas de la chance pas mais je pense
aussi mais ça du pool mélange away
tétreault je dois partager ton espace
vital avec quelqu'un a déjà qui supporte
pas que de lave son linge avec celui de
notre fille
je refuse d'être un petit bourgeois tu
entends je refuse je refuse je refuse la
favela personnes dans le monde et plus à
gauche que toi et à ouvrir cette porte
géant bg group on envoie nous voulons
d'avoir des convictions on va y arriver
ce à quoi me fier d'avoir voté à gauche